vous avez vu cette info là hier
franchement l'Olympique de Marseille qui
dev recevoir hier soir l'Olympique
lyonnaais tuas vu ça mais à l'occasion
d'un Olympico qui clôturait donc la 10e
journée de Ligue 1 et a pas joué parce
que en fait le bus des lonais été pris
d'assaut par des supporters adverses
violemment caillassé et il y a le le
l'entraîneur lyonnais Fabio Grosso
l'entraîneur d'union touché au visage
lui il direain qu'est-ce que je suis
venu faire dans cette galère non mais s
rigol 30 jours d'
regardez
à côté du bus
malade regarde oh là là VI le carreau
cassé
[Musique]
làbasos
oh bon il s'est passé quoi mon Jacques
Jacques vendrou voilà une
légende
le
bonheur je suis content de te voir moi
aussi je suis content de te voir en plus
moi aussi tuas fait tu veux pas une
chemise toi non non non c'est bon ton
t-shirt moi j'aime bien ton t-shirt tu
ve moi je vais te donner tu es sûr tu
veux pas je te donne tout ce que tu veux
le pantalon et puis j'ai pas vu le
pantalon c'est c'est ton
style c'est pas mon style si ça ça va
JAC ça fait longemp que je très bien moi
aussi bon alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé hier soir encord ben je crois que
il faut être clair on a affaire à des à
des voyou gens qui n'ont rien à faire
dans le football c'est ça qui n'ont rien
à faire d'ailleurs dans le sport en
général et ce matin j'ai encore pris un
cour moral parce que moi j'aime le
football et je crois que sur ce plateau
il y a beaucoup de personnes qui adorent
le football et là je crois très
honnêtement Gérard lenvin a rendu
hommage tout à l'heure à l'organisation
extraordinaire du rugby je crois
qu'actuellement on est en train de
perdre notre football parce que ce qui
s'est passé hier soir à Marseille c'est
certainement sur ces 30 ans l'une des
choses les plus graves qui existe dans
le football s'il y a pas eu des morts
c'est un véritable miracle parce que les
les supporters enfin ces pseudo
supporters de l'Olympique de Marseille
et même de l'Olympique yonet qui ont mis
la pagaille dans le stade quelques
minutes avant faut pas les oublier et
bien ils ont fa ils ont failli tout
simplement tuer l'entraîneur de de cette
équipe de l'Olympique de Marseille de de
l'Olympique Lonis faut pas se voiler la
face l'entraîneur est blessé grièvement
il a une commotion cérébral il se pose
des questions c'est des pavés qui ont
été lancés sur le quart des supp
sur l'écart des supporters de Lyon et
sur le quart de l'équipe de de
l'Olympique lonnais c'est pas des
cailloux c'est pas j'ai entendu ce matin
des gens qui disait oui ils ont jeté des
ils ont jeté des des trucs de bière et
cetera c'est des pavés c'est des pavés
et c'est ça qui est grave et donc là le
football est en danger et c'est la
première fois depuis 30 ans enfin g le
football comme comme nous tous Je c'est
la première fois où là il faut faire
quelque chose il faut les interdire à
vie faut pas faut pas lesiner ils sont
en train actuellement de tuer notre
jouet les acteurs c'est une porte de
sortie pour les gens en difficultés avec
le spectacle de de la famille l'envin le
football c'est pareil la Coupe du Monde
c'est pareil Roland garot c'est pareil
c'est des portes de sortie pour les gens
qui ont difficulté de voir un beau grand
moment de sport ils peuvent rêver et là
ils sont en train de le tuer mais je
suis d'accord JAC tu restes un a voà
c'est tout je voulais le dire parce que
et c'est pour ça que j'étais très
content d'être là ce soir parce que je
crois qu'il faut pas faut pas les h iner
il faut les interdir de stade comme ils
ont fait en Angleterre en Angleterre il
y a plus d'embrouille en Italie a
dans d'unêtre humun entraur d'un
champion du monde de football c'est pas
parce qu'il est champion du monde de
football
qui comment ça s'est arrêté comment ça
s'est arrêté la folie comment elle
srê jou dempique r
de leur vestiare à l'Olympique de
Marseille que les supporters ont été
plus ou moins arrêtés mis en garde à vue
ils sont neufs ils sont neuf alors qu'
j'ai entendu ce matin sur europein
PASC ce que je veux dire il y avait la
police ça att o dès qu'on a besoin de la
police on est cont alors moi je vais te
dire hier hier il y avait 500 policiers
pour surveiller l'ordonnancement de ce
match à haut niveau et les policiers ils
ont fait leur boulot ils ont fait le
maximum ils ont essayé de protéger tout
le monde mais tu peux pas protéger tout
le monde tu peux pas protéger 60000
personnes c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible il ét là il étai là é ils
étaient là je suis d'accord avec je suis
d'accord sur tout Gérard je suis aussi
triste bien sûr pour on est triste pour
lyonnais bien entendu et surtout pour
l'entraîneur lyonnais qui doit être doit
se dire qu'est-ce que je suis venu
[__] dans cette galère et il y a aussi
des supporters marseillais qui arrêent
pas d'écrire et qui disent ils nous ont
gâché la fête ils nous ont gâché notre
match et il nous ont fait pass pour les
voyou alors que nous on veut juste
soutenir l'Olympique de Marseille il y a
beaucoup de supporters marseillais qui
disent que ces mecs là c'est pas des
supporters c'est juste des deson pas ce
qu'il dit mais et les supporters
lyonnais aussi dans le stade ont pas été
beaucoup mieux
c tot hier c'était c'était n'importe
quoi Jacques franchement c'est quoi ça
non mais c'est je crois très honnêtement
que il s'est passé des choses comme on a
dit tout à l'heure immensément
gravissime il faut absolument
sanctionner alors je sais c'est
récurrent tout le monde dit il faut
sanctionner mais personne ne sanctionne
personne il arrive à un moment il va y
avoir un psychodrame c'est obligatoire
hier soir je l'ai dit s'il y a pas une
mort c'est c'est c'est miraculeux et il
faut absolument quand je vois quand je
vois le président de la FIFA le dénommé
Infantino qui se permet de dire la
violence n'a pas sa place dans le
football mais faudrait quand même lui
rappeler que la violence n'a sa place
nulle part nulle part nulle part et pas
uniquement dans le football et s'il y a
de la violence dans la société et bien
justement ça ça va dans le football il
faut il faut absolument sanctionner il
faut les interdire de stade il faut les
mettre je je suis pas procureur he ni
juge je dis simplement qu'il faut il
faut leur faire peur faut les mettre en
prison pendant quelques mois et puis
c'est tout puis là ils vont comprendre
ils vont plus faire les barbau parce que
là c'est une 20 là c'est une une
vingtaine de mecs un mec qui ont cassé
le rêve de je sais pas combien de
téléspectateurs de je sais pas combien
l'auditeur et comment non lui là il fait
comme ça quand tu parles il fait comme
ça on dirait le cerveau Dav le G comme
ça parles l' il est comme ça on dirait C
sans non simplement il y avait plus
d'une vingtaine de gars il y avait au
moins 100 personnes avec des cagoules
mais c'est vrai mais c'est vrai je dis
une vingtaine de personnes je je je me
suis je suis légèrement trompé c'est 100
personnes c'est 100 personnes dont
beaucoup été cagoulé des fous et je dois
dire aussi un truc qui est élément qui
est important c'est que les les 3/4 les
deux quart des supporters et les carart
de de l'Olympique Lonis enfin le carart
siglé de l'Olympique Lonis a pris un
chemin h où il y avait des travaux alors
je sais pas pourquoi je sais pas comment
ils sont arrivés là c'est ils ont pris
des travaux ils roulaient à de à l'heure
est-ce que c'était est-ce que c'était
prémédité pourquoi pas et ils ont pris
des des pavés ont
l mais il y a des travaux il y a des
travaux énormes à Marseille en ce moment
il ça sera pas durer pardon il y aidalgo
à Marseille est des travaux à côté de
boulevard Rabateau et cetera il y a
beaucoup d'avenu autour de du stade où
il y a des travaux il y en aura ça va
durer jusqu'aux Jeux Olympiques au moins
mais là où Jacques dit quelque chose de
très juste c'est que ils se renvoient
tous la balle et il y a un problème dans
le football aujourd'hui c'est que alors
les clubs ne sont pas responsables de ce
qui se passe à l'extérieur donc ils
disent bah ils peuvent pas aller faire
la police à 1 km euh de l'extérieur du
stade c'est c'est c'est normal c'est la
règle et de l'autre côté j'ai entendu
les déclarations des ministres
aujourd'hui qui ont tendance à dire mais
c'est au club de faire la police
eux-même mais c'est compliqué d'aller
faire la police lorsqu'on n'est pas
responsable donc
aussi aussi le niveau le niveau des
déclarations des dirigeants des clubs je
ve dire quand Pablo Langoria qui dit ah
bon vous êtes sûr vous êtes sûr que ça
s'est passé comme ça vous êtes vous
n'exagérez pas un petit peu et quand
vous avez le dénommé Textor qui ne sait
même pas qu'il est à Marseille je
croyais que c'était une marque de
préservatif mais moi aussi mais moi
aussi moi je Textor il a fait une
interview mais était affligeante il
savait même pas où il était je dirais et
là il y a il y a ils se rendent pas
compte ils se rendent pas compte que
actuellement que ce soit la fédération
que ça soit la Ligue que ce soit l'UEFA
que ça soit toutes les instances que le
football je le répète une nouvelle fois
et je profite de d'être chez Cyril le
football est en danger de mort tout est
en danger moi je vais dire en ce moment
moi je peux parler du football parce que
c'est je connais le mieux mais mais mais
en plus en plus moi ce qui m'a gonflé
moi ce qui m'a gonflé moi ce qui m'a
gonflé c'est ce qui se passe dans le
monde actuellement quand on est en train
de créer des pagailles phénoménales je
veux dire du côté de de Marseille un
petit peu de respect pour ce qui se
passe dans le reste du monde arrêtons
arrêtons c'est tellement ridicule ce qui
se passe à Marseille c'est tellement
c'est tellement pin c'est tellement
scandaleux alors que il y a des morts
partout au Proche et au Moyen-Orient
mais un petit peu de respect un tout
petit peu de respect restez chez vous si
vous vous réveillez le matin pour vous
dire tiens je vais rendre des gens
malheureux vous avez réussi en ce qui
concerne la microociété du football il
faut que ça sache dire qui éta ouais j'
étais parce que j'ai bossé juste à côté
qui s'appelle le parc Chan qui juste à
côté du Vélodrome à 200 m et quand je
suis sorti j'ai vu la j'ai vu la scène
qui était assez impressionnante
d'ailleurs et effectivement on la la
l'ambiance a évolué au départ c'était
super il y avait des familles enfin les
vrais des vrais spécialistes et des
vrais afficiados de l'OM en plus j'ai
discuté avec eux et tout ça et d'un seul
coup on a vu des mecs arriver avec des
des casques en cagoulé et c'est parti ça
arriv c'est parti très très rapidement
il y avait pas beaucoup de flic
pardonnez-moi mais il y avait pas
beaucoup de parmi de de policiers
policier éit plus du côté du Vélodrome
que sur la sur cette place justement où
il y a le le parc Chano et cette
histoire me fait rappeler et si on peut
faire un rappel qui a été le même
problème avec l'Algérie face à l'Égypte
sur le retour pour la qualification de
la Coupe du monde et ils ont subi la
même agression merci en tout cas Jacques
d'être venu n voir TU j'aimerais que tu
viennes nous voir plus souvent parce que
c'est embrasse tous trs bon moment à
nous c'est toujours un bonheur de te
voir donc il faut que tu viennes nous
voir franchement